you
hi everyone's cherry among chests come
and going to play a five-o game okay I
had a I had to double check there and a
couple seeks out one four five oh one
four three two so know increment here we
have in Atkins defense I'm not a big fan
of going for the four pawns attack so
I'm not going to play F form let's take
and see how they wreak it recapture
first off okay
Knight f3 knight c6 they're probably
going to fee and keto let's play Knight
f3 and I may invest a tempo with h3 well
not now so how do i how do I do this I'm
thinking about Bishop e3 and then Knight
- D - yeah let's do this
if I play Bishop e2 there's ideas of
taking the night and then taking on c4
so I need to take some care of this
square that said let's go here also Rick
see when I like that it defends c4
directly let's break this pin and I
think I'm satisfied so far with this
formation of minor pieces let's ask him
a question more long-term this is useful
to have h2 for my king it's quite
natural to have the rook here and now
this is really the first moment where
I'm thinking I wonder about 94 to g3 and
this move might defy be played maybe let
me reinforce c4 just to Ted stead on 94
push after the smoke clears I'm not
saddled with an isolated deep on
so on tv4 night here okay that's running
right into this they probably have to
react to that so my Queen and Bishop are
there now so I think I could take this
opportunity to maybe push black around a
little bit with d5 I don't think that
that Knight has a good square um-hmm or
maybe a slower buildup let me go with a
slower build-up it's not quite clear to
me what exactly this movement that's me
all right I thought that that might
happen
but I'm not too afraid of it let's stay
on these nice squares c3 and f3
controlling all four Center squares rook
up to d1
maybe Queen to be - lets get this rook
here they can't feel so comfortable
having the Queen here Queenie sevens
quite natural okay now they're pushing
okay let's push and now with this last
sequence of moves we have a majority on
the Queen side so let me go Queen here
preparing b4 looking to expand this
three versus two majority on the Queen
side if every four this well this is
going to need some support no doubt I am
also opposite their Bishop so I have to
be a little bit careful let's make sure
I can meet beats b6 with the b4 they're
preparing for the opening up at the a
fall I think I should still just
voluntarily push here so let's do it
you know I have to fight back so I'm on
the clock here so this night you can't
feel so secure anymore hmm
is just a pawn off the board eh actually
why am I not considering Knight b-52
here let's go here first get out of this
this bishops view keep some pressure on
this square and now let's jump in Knight
d6 we'll hit with tempo yeah I like that
I have pressure on this square with my
queen
that doesn't feel like it should be good
um let's go here for starters and can I
not just start pushing black around some
I think I could do this and I believe
I'll be able to work around a knight on
e5 Knight a5 Queen up they take here
I'll have connected passed pawns I have
to be work a little bit careful of some
sacrifice here undermining my knight
position hmm
my queen is unprotected so if I push
here my knight is a little bit stranded
he's pinned maybe I could look to
reroute this bishop okay
a bunch of pins so knight c6 is a
possibility but these bishops do really
well to defend these two pawns these
bishops are nightmares what is that
mouth do not understand that I think
they thought I had to take with the rook
or queen Wow well that's a sudden end
huh they missed something there clearly
I don't know that that was a mouse lip
that's uh I don't know Night Moves
usually don't have mouse lips windpipe
moves of all pieces but I don't know
something was missed there I think I am
the better side here because of these
guys connected pastors we both have
connected pastors but I have well my
pawns are a bit further hmm I think I'm
the one who who did benefit from this
structural change as soon as d5 and c5
is in let me just call to the analysis
fast forward a little bit right around
here this d5 and c5 I think I'm the
better side here cuz I'm looking to plan
the queenside with this shift I have a
queen side majority and black has a
central majority I have a three versus
two on the Queen side black has a two
versus one in the center so I'm looking
to go with B 4 a 4 B 5 like I did in the
game well a 3 and B 4 but this is the
idea black on the other hand should be
shooting for this but it's difficult
because of the pressure that I have on
d5 with both night and for winner of e5
hits the rook I'm slightly ahead
timewise and I am playing with this
space advantage yeah I must be better
here I have really good pieces good
control over the center hard to argue
with the knight placement you know hard
to argue with both Knights their
positions hmm maybe right around here
black has to shoot for something
different but it's already a little bit
iffy because with this pawn on c5 this
d6 square the one that I hopped to it's
a tricky piece to work around for sure
tonight on d6 hmm well good look what
could black have done maybe a little bit
different I wonder I think that this is
quite alright
actually you know what the other thing
to look into and we'll have a look at it
with stock fishes to go about
development with this Bishop g6
bishop here striking at my Center and
then maybe going for an e5 move I'm
pretty sure that this is another
approach to address this pawn duo with
an e5 strike and shaking it just a
little bit further on d5 if this is how
I'm to react the knight can reposition
to e7 and think about f5 and even
something like f5 creating a pawn duo
here on the Kings side this would
actually this is already threatening to
pick up my bishop
it's an idea I'm pretty sure I've seen
this idea on the black side I don't get
to play against the aliens defense too
often but I'm pretty sure if you're
going with a fiend cut out and striking
a d4 with the knight Bishop and then in
the end and E 5 pawn will make this pawn
duo flinch as it played out I was able
to maintain this pawn duo and yeah
eventually grab some space after they
played d5 I got in c5 there was a little
bit of a time waste here with Bishop f6
it ran into 94 in the Knight c3 so he's
slightly improved he was on d2 he got to
e4 with tempo he dropped into c3 this is
again a really good post for the Knights
yeah white is definitely the better side
here by how much I'm not sure yeah I
guess the one other thing we could have
we could have a look at what when I look
at it what the computer is was I correct
- maybe nuts let's see right around here
was I correct - not go in for d5 here I
wonder if the computer would be calling
out for this right now
something tells me it's maybe a little
bit too early takes takes maybe Knight
here with a double attack against this
hmm it's a bit tricky
I don't know III think it'll be alright
but you know I I think in the end what I
really didn't want was to have to
babysit upon
he's now isolated and potentially
vulnerable yeah I don't I don't know
that I could really be bad here but yeah
I think it was more of a structure thing
I wanted to stay clear of an isolated
pawn situation hmm okay well we're gonna
have a look at it with the computer so
just give me a second I'll pull it up
okay stockfish let us see what we can
learn from you so no issues with this
organisation of the minor pieces backup
right here it's fine with ease six but
also we're seeing g6 pop up and this is
really the one I want to investigate
just a little bit so far as I still go
up go with this same setup connecting
the Knights Bishop g7 mm Bishop e2
castles castles get some natural stuff
in and okay here's even an improvement
over what I was suggesting he five is
the idea but I inserted first knight c6
d5 could hit before e5 is in so before
this idea of d5 can hit with tempo
against a piece black is already in a
position to strike with e5 and should I
play d5 now this night could think about
a six into the c5 square so it's still
the right idea as far as what pawn break
to shoot for the e5 strike Bishop g7 and
e5 is another
approach here for black suppose on e5h
three chop-chop
and then knight c6 d 597 and for a
second it just popped up g4 but that's a
pretty committal move White's playing
with the two bishops mm-hmm I don't know
how I feel about haha g4 yeah I'm
leaning more towards the other
suggestion Bishop d3 and I guess this
night could still drop in there Knight
f5 and it's also even considering me for
the exchange of the e pawn for the SI
phan yeah I'm not sure how valuable the
bishops are in this position my x-factor
bishop is the light-square bishop but he
kind of struggles you know on this
diagonal the b12 h7 diagonal he's biting
on a rock
what other diagonals are there really
this d5 pawn gets in his way
mm-hmm okay and it's it's another it's
another approach here another way to
organize the minor pieces for black to
go with the Fein keto so E 6 isn't bad
but let's see how black could have still
done better with this EC 6 Bishop e7
deployment pretty natural stuff coming
in just kind of doing a quick blunder
check here
b3 doesn't like b3 Queen b3 oh I don't
know about that hmm it feels a little
weird I should probably explain why
exactly it feels weird just something
about having the Queen on the 3rd rank
here with still so many pieces on the
board and I know like maybe Knight a5
valuable tempo at some stage I know how
does more
concerned about reinforcing c4 I think
right around this moment in the game I
was considering efore but I thought d5
yeah
oh here's the other point can maybe
consider taking and then playing d5 and
what is this going to do it's going to
grant black access to the d5 square with
this fork against the knight and c4 pawn
I lose control of d5 with my pawn it
even points out d5 right away
yeah and we're seeing a shift of course
you know this is this is a big deal very
tempting to maybe think oh let's throw
my knight in the center but yeah d5 is a
good way to break up this pawn duo C
takes D Knight takes D yeah sometimes
Black has this type of position and
they're still struggling to get their
LightSquared Bishop working he'll be
back here but he's an active piece
he's already outside of the pawn chain
we might say there's no way black can be
bad here they have good control over the
squared directly in front of this
isolated pawn and they have no issue
with their LightSquared bishop in this
case okay so short story here is that
that's why I did not want to go with e4
because of the d5 reply and so that was
my reason at this point to play b3 so
that I can play Knight e4 if I'm just
making a passing move to illustrate I
think I could go 94 without d5 being so
much of an issue it still calls for d5
but the difference here is that I
haven't given up control of d5 on takes
whoops the bishops hit but let's just
suppose the bishop wasn't hit on takes
I'm able to recapture and maintain
control over here that's that's the idea
behind b3 keep control over d5 there
maybe for what should black be doing
right around here after b3 mm-hmm f5
oh okay it's not initially I thought it
was just top 94 but it's threatening F
for dropping my bishop hmm I'd have to
take some action here yeah you know
that's a pretty serious move f5 hmm
Peter calls for d4 and says it's about
equal you know things are certainly
sharpening up here he takes and night to
d4 well yeah okay it's getting really
messy now threatens a night take and our
night to e6 with the fork and they takes
bishop takes okay yeah it's getting
pretty wild but okay f5 was an idea here
for black and also bishop g6 okay that's
a more solid approach than this
committal f5 bishop g6 stops 94 and
maybe then black can look forward to
Bishop f6 okay Bishop f6 it is I got
that tempo in night g6 d5 is another
idea he takes C takes I was pointing out
this maybe five exchange rooks and then
Knight g6 I guess it's okay hmm you have
to give up the bishop and then queen
daddy too challenging this Knight okay
another way to approach it again I
wasn't so much a fan of having that
happen to my structure playing with an
isolated pawn it's not bad but it wasn't
my cup of tea let's just say Oh with
Queen d2 it doesn't like that
I guess d5 is good here huh hmm okay so
black should have
struck at my knight with d5 right here
and I think I was gonna go to c3 you
could do this but I feel like after a
bishop g6 my knight on G my knight on G
3 is out of play so I'm pretty sure I
would have leaned more towards Knight c3
although hmm
like g3 does actually force a Bishop
takes Knight as otherwise we end up with
the similar structure well the same
structure in the game I get the c5
advance in and we have this now the
lines drawn in the game the majority on
the Queen side versus black central
majority so the way to stop that at
night g3 is to take the knight and then
start to be disruptive to my pieces
apparently with Bishop 83 hmm if I'm
stepping up here I guess night b4 okay
it's getting pretty direct d5 was
another move to consider here for black
the moment where it hits against a panc
form I want to mention one other thing I
don't think I was able to voice it
during the game but if I go with this
natural deployment the c-4 square is a
bit sensitive you know if let's say
Bishop e7 Bishop e2 this d5 move if I'm
following up with c5 I believe that the
knight could think about jumping here at
some point and I know I just wanted to
give some extra security to the c-4
square to kind of offset this night on
b6 I kind of didn't want him I didn't
want the B six nights presence to be
felt in the game I was kind of making
moves in a way that restricted this
night or you know I didn't want him to
enter play so easily so that's why I
opted for the Queen Knights placement on
d2 instead of C 3
so getting to this point again they had
d5 right here instead it was Bishop g6
ninth c3 you know it's a slight pull for
white and you know I guess after d5 now
it's starting to become a bit more of an
issue here for black like Queen B - I
guess a3 is another idea also I could
have considered right away Knight to be
5 into d6 only a few moves later did I
even consider Knight b5 here but why why
did I not consider this at the very
first moment after c5 Knight here I
should have already my I should have
been trained much sooner to the d6
square and at least considered Knight be
five 2d six right now so that's just a
small correction that I'm making here
with my thinking it should have had that
that thought process should have ran
through my mind right now this is a hole
in the black position I have control
over with the pawn how can I get a piece
there is the next question okay play
Queen B - first the Queen side pawns
going Queen e7 likes Queen b3 okay I'm
happy about that
it says rook a1 and also Queen to b3 has
line two there's kind of a passing move
to just getting out of the bishops way
pressure on d5 and now Knight b5 and b6
I jumped right in and we just had that
blunder here I guess b5 is a problem oh
boy
what did I miss oh there's a tactical
shot for black here undermining the
knight immediately with Knight takes d4
turn night here I maintain the advantage
after queen before and then what they
blundered and that was it so we both
missed this tactical idea after b5
there's Knight takes d4 Bishop takes
Bishop takes Knight takes and then V
takes o hmm oh that's really sharp
that's a lot to calculate allowing this
fork taking here what does black have
here after the smoke clears
yeah I have the exchange but they have
two pawns for the exchange so and that's
a pretty strong pawn Center it's still
messy but yikes okay
yeah Knight to d4 that's a tough one to
calculate I gotta say after Knight a5 I
guess there isn't anything hmm maybe
speaking too quick here
it's not losing but it's got to be a
little bit uncomfortable here to say the
least to work around the d6 Knight Queen
f8 I guess Bishop e7 is the idea hmm
it's a bit tricky
I think the idea here is to really not
allow that this structure to even come
about and I know it feels feels kind of
easier to play on the white side with
these pawns a little further advanced
when compared to a no no blacks central
majority you know queen f8 Bishop f4
Bishop e7 you know it's coming for c6
here connected past pawn yeah this is
really tough to play you have to
consider who's like rook to d8 all of a
sudden a nun takes takes you're getting
the piece back tricky to play for black
I'm much easier to play here for white
so you know the big thing here was the
structure this is the thing I'm taking
away from it this opportunity for black
to have the d5 break-in right now
and also that tactical resource a little
bit later on on the d4 square at this
moment here as soon as I play b5 and
weakened my c5 square there is in fact
in an opportunity to undermine this d6
night
they ended up blundering here not sure
what they had in mind with that but okay
well a sudden end to this one but I
believe there's still some good points
to be taking away from it and I hope you
were able to take something away from it
as usual feel free to leave any feedback
in the comment section below and I'll
catch you in the next video that's all
for now take care bye
you